then she said no it'll be soon on the
show we have a segment called hashtag
because toddlers where parents share
their wildest toddler stories mostly
just so I can feel less alone but since
it's almost Halloween we decided to do a
special version of our favorite hashtag
by having you tell us the creepiest
things for toddlers I've done I haven't
seen any of these responses yet so let's
get spooked
[Music]
two years ago when my son was four he
insisted on going as penny wise from it
for Halloween we went to a neighborhood
Halloween party and he creeped everyone
out in full costume carrying a single
red balloon that is creepy you might
want to make sure you leave animals
around that's awesome kids just like to
be creepy and fun like that good for you
for not being scared oh my gosh it just
literally it just says I woke up to this
that's how she woke up what I have to
meet this kid that is so creepy that's
my husband as a kid that's what that is
he loves scaring people it's so
four years ago my then ten-year-old son
told me he couldn't sleep at night
because of all the people talking a few
weeks later in broad daylight I pull
into my driveway to see this on my son's
bedroom window we left and never went
back
paid someone to move our stuff after
further investigation of the picture we
determined that there are in fact
several faces and skulls in the window
which would explain why he couldn't
sleep through all the people talking
what what does that mean
no people Sadie believe in ghosts or not
here's the thing I don't want to believe
in ghosts
I don't want we have enough crap going
on in this realm let's handle this and
then we can move on to other realms that
is super creepy you can't see it like
get in there but like that's creepy
[Music]
my son speaks in this demonic voice
sometimes and I'm legit terrified like
okay Satan returned home whoa that's
kind of weird but awesome I don't know
I'm kind of impressed by it at the same
time when my now seven year old was four
she had an imaginary friend who lived in
their playroom she would tell me he got
mad when I raised my voice she also had
an imaginary friend with red eyes who
lived in the Attic glad we don't live in
the house anymore if my kid came in and
said I have an imaginary friend with red
eyes and lives in our attic well I'd
move amongst other things is this real
you think that's real or people are
making that up because that's crazy
trust the people okay my son asked me
what my mom who had passed away years
before look like after I die I don't
even like where this is headed after I
described her he asked is that her
standing next to you oh my gosh if that
legit happened to me
I was watching my niece who was five at
the time and out of nowhere she got
really sad and said I don't want you to
die I said honey you don't have to worry
about that it won't be until I'm really
old then she said no it'll be soon then
she said no it'll be soon oh are you
creeped out and my the only one that's
creeped out y'all look normal
this is weird when my son was just
little he came into my room said mom the
guy that sits in my room at night could
you ask him to leave are you for real
there was no actual live person in his
room you know that girl pie had like a
camera like we all stand was in our kids
rooms no that's so creepy y'all I would
move all of these things I would move
very far away when my daughter was three
I told her to pick up her toys and she
said no and I asked her why not and she
said because I never made you pick up
your toys When I was your mommy what
backstory my mom died when I was 18 wait
what wait when my daughter was three I
told her to pick up her toys and she
said no and I asked her why not she said
because I never made you pick up your
toys when I was your mommy wide like
wait what okay that's a very clever
little girl that's not real incarnation
like you know I'm saying she should be a
lawyer that is quick on your feet
I don't know my daughter can come up
with some pretty crazy stuff to get out
of cleaning yeah just being honest I
always want to hear about the crazy
things that your kids are doing so find
me on Twitter Facebook and Instagram and
use the hashtag hashtag because toddlers
to tell me your story and maybe I'll
read yours next time cuz Wow kids are
creepy bye I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this